i'm going to say congrats i watched the
first episode before getting to talk to
you i'm going to say congrats i think
i think you guys did it
did we
i did i do i think listen you're i think
it's about time that star trek was that
you got you made a kids show you made
star trek aimed at kids and it's you
know that's the way to introduce new
fans to star trek you know i think that
it's uh it's a really smart idea
thank you thank you very much thank you
um so
i guess my question is why did it take
this long or was it you guys who sort of
came in and said this like we should do
this no
we honestly give credit to alex kurtzman
i think you know he was just looking at
trek
and as it's continuing to age or with
the new shows that
you go down the toy aisles and you don't
see the star trek lunch boxes anymore
you don't see
you know you see a whole aisle of star
wars toys and you don't see anything for
trek but not just that but the canon is
so rich it's it's so rich it's
intimidating i think for even adults who
are like i'm kind of curious about star
trek but where do i start what do i do i
don't i i don't want people to feel like
they're you know
foolish for not knowing the difference
between a vulcan and a romulan you know
where uh this is a show that is is gonna
spoon feed people who
who want to start on the bottom floor
and work their way up and get into
starfleet so to speak
the the first episode sets up what could
be the antagonist of the entire series
and i'm just curious are you aiming for
each season to have its own sort of arc
or as the antagonist we meet in the
first season in the first episode the
overarching antagonist
that's typically how we like to write i
i want you know we want this show to
feel like a giant mini mini series or
like a cinematic
you know event series and i and we want
the story to come to a conclusion we
want you know my dream is this show
keeps going and there's it's almost like
it's almost like taking a trek film and
breaking it out you know and each you
know i just that's what i grew up yeah
every season should wrap up but at the
same time you know invite what the next
conflict is what what you know
they're a long way from home and it's
not simply getting home isn't the only
thing they need to do there's a lot of
growth that they got and we're also
coexisting in the same space as picard
and so we don't want to be
some alternate mirror universe of
characters we are in the prime universe
with them and so there's a lot of cause
and effect with the other series in
ourselves
what would have happened if kate had
said no
we would have gone to picard and it
would have been a terrible terrible show
to watch picard overseeing a bunch of
teenagers
right would you watch that i don't know
listen i'll watch i'll watch any
anything with patrick stewart is going
to you know
it sounds like a it sounds like an 80s
sitcom or something with wesley picard
overseeing a bunch of kids on the bridge
for all three of you guys um i am
curious what are you most looking
forward for people to actually see on
the series
i think the the the diversity of the
experience
you know how
how
big and small how intimate and how
spectacular that journey is and also how
uh reverent it is to what has come
before
uh and inventive it is going forward and
that those are the conversation that i
hope
uh
multi-generational fans and new fans and
all fans will have and just talk about
you know the places and the people and
species and and and the mechanism and
the logic of what makes you know trek
trek you know that's that's what i'm
excited about can i just add like what
ben and everyone's done with that pilot
the there's the you know adventure
sequences are yes big and awesome right
and but my favorite moments are like dal
discovering the ship and his hand
touching it and these like sensitive
moments and the music from nami you know
it just comes to life for me those quiet
moments the camera's sitting on a face
and they just
it moves me you know i was moved when i
was watching it
i'm excited for like i feel like what's
great about the trek community is that
there's you know they break down
they'll have conference in-depth
conversations breaking down what's
possible in the holodeck or which ship
would win in a fight and i love this
idea of bringing getting kids into this
conversation as well you know
hearing an eight-year-old talk about um
you know the value of rock talk on a
bridge you know i think these are some
important things that
you know i'm i'm excited to have those
conversations in the household with my
kids and i hope
i already have to stop sucks i will just
leave it there and say congrats on the
first episode looking forward to seeing
you know i'm looking forward to a new
generation watching
thank you so much thank you cool thank
you have a great day i like your shirt
thank you thank you